i want to talk about project veritas
because i've i mentioned this
a bit yesterday a bit earlier today but
i really do think that what they're
doing
is probably the most consequential and
important
whatever you want to call it fighting
battles that anyone
in the culture war is doing because
james is not only doing the
investigations publishing videos of
people saying these things
he's fighting the legal battles suing
the new york times
which has has uh uh let me let me ask
you this
let me let me i'll make a few more
points soon in the new york times suing
cnn
now he's gonna be suing twitter he's not
backing down he is going nuclear and
he's doing so much more than anyone else
is willing to do
he's willing to just refuse to bend the
knee in any capacity
and there are so many people that i i
get mad at these cops
in the minneapolis area who can see
what's happening with show and his other
cops and they're like well i'm going to
stay here it's fine
i'm not going to stand up i'm not going
to speak out because a lot of cops did
they quit they refused
we had this story people mentioned i
think it was in denver i guess like 20
cops were like nope we out
but some of these cops are like i'll
keep my head down and say nothing james
is the opposite of that that's why i
respect him
because he's like i'm going to stand up
and scream twice as loud now
so let's let's talk about this i have a
question for you will um
in the new york times lawsuit for with
veritas the judge
said uh when he so the new york times
filed a motion to dismiss
saying that their reporters were making
opinions which are unactionable and the
judge said
if you if you have a fact-based news
story and your reporters interject their
opinions
it stands to reason you should inform
your readers of that for one i'm curious
your opinions on his ruling and what
that might mean but
does this in any way set precedent that
we could use moving forward i mean
a new york state of court opinion is is
weak precedent
generally because it's you know it's
it's a new york judge applying new york
defamation law in a new york court so
but it works for new york i mean it
probably works in federal district court
it's also not an appellate court ruling
which
really you know if you actually want
like precedent that like binds future
courts
and really influences courts far and
wide a single
state district judge is not going to do
it generally
yeah that said uh i think you know this
could go up on appeal and you could get
an appellate opinion
from the new york because i assume the
new york times is going to appeal this
um if they don't settle it and i think
it could be valuable there
i think i think it's just generally i
mean it's a great opinion though and
it provides a sort of template for how
to approach these things when the new
york times does this in the future or
any other outlet does it i mean
that's a very persuasive point like you
don't get to suddenly claim you're an
opinion outlet when
you're writing a news article and then
saying somebody is deceptive and
misinforming people
i've had a lot of lawyers tell me this
that when a news article smears me
it's an opinion and i'm like how does a
someone claim to be fact-based real news
publish opinion pieces and and get away
with it without without any
any accountability i mean it's you know
even then remember he just got past a
motion to dismiss
he's still got to prove actual malice i
mean he's alleged it
uh and i think there was a circumstance
where you know for some reason
uh the timing of in particular i think
it was the timing of this article and
how quickly it went up
right it was like within 63 minutes
within 63 minutes or something that was
what the judge used to infer actual
malice and infer that they didn't even
have time to try
right they still published it anyway the
new york times i think they claimed that
if you read james wikipedia that shows
that he has
no ability to sue anyone at any point
because he is
so defamed it's an interesting argument
because i get it
right the average person sees this and
assumes all of these things are true and
correct
so that brings me to the wikipedia
argument where if wikipedia is claiming
that sex
like we got very serious problems right
now
i guess the issue is james is like one
of the few people
going to war like where's everybody else
i don't know how else you
you you you know well for rally the
truth for just a little help i
pull up bill ayers wikipedia i don't
know if you guys can do that oh yeah but
like i just from the weather
this is the weather underground
terrorist right weather underground
they're on
uh excuse me will excuse me
william charles ayers is an american
elementary education
theorist oh oh yeah and he was a leader
of a militant group
described by the fbi as a terrorist
group okay that opposed your involvement
in the vietnam war
that's all they did he is known for his
1960s radical activism
and his later work in education reform
curriculum and instruction
oh he is that's what he's known for they
say
setting all over the country and they
say project project veritas is a
far-right
con activist group that engages in
disinformation
you're talking about enrique tario the
chairman of the parabola is a far-right
neo-fascist and male
and engages in only violence that sounds
right yeah right
like not setting off bombs by the way
right yeah how many bombs says
zero zero it does say in the next
paragraph he engaged in a campaign of
bombing public buildings including
police stations the us capital and the
pentagon
secondary wow thanks for bringing that
to my attention in the second paragraph
why doesn't it say william charles ayers
is a far-left terrorist and conspiracy
theorist
who is most known for engaging in
terroristic plots and insurrection
against the united states
that would be pretty accurate yeah or at
least like you got to have the same sort
of neutralizing like i mean i've seen so
many people on our side
who have wikipedia profiles that begin
just like the one about enrique tario
far right's an opinion
it's yeah it's an immediately it's
opinion saying william charles ayer is
an
american elementary educational theorist
is a fact
you can argue some of it's an opinion
like what does it mean to be a theorist
but no like he does that
yes you could also say he's a terrorist
that's also a fact also
but if you said he was far left far
right
you know or whatever they say
self-described communist you know why
because calling him a communist could be
an opinion as
they say he was uh you know a founding
man co-founder of the weather
underground a self-described communist
revolutionary group
they're very careful when it comes to
bill ayers with everyone else from
people like mike cernovich jack pasok or
project veritas james o'keefe
they assert a bunch of opinions they're
deceptive they're misleading they're
conspiracy theorists they're far right
none of which are statements of fact
why is wikipedia engaging in opinion
articles about people
it's 2 30 2 30 is so broad and i mean
this is actually one area where i think
i really think we could do without 230 i
mean i think you know
or very much narrow it so that like you
know wikipedia okay it has its little
it has its pages and people can access
them if they want but if they show up on
google searches which they do
then that's wikipedia publishing them so
they're they're now liable for whatever
difference i
i i made this argument the other day
this bill
this let me let me pull up james o'keefe
this is going to be good well we we
showed this the other day we'll pull up
we'll pull up james
it's an american conservative political
activist and provocateur what's a
provocateur that's an opinion
what has he done that's been that can be
definitively stated as as being a
provocateur he's a journalist
american journalist the investigative
journal has has james ever called
himself a conservative activist
i don't think so i don't think he's ever
referred to himself into himself that
way
i don't think he's ever referred to
himself as an activist
bombed federal buildings yes james
o'keefe
filmed people saying some things they
wish they did one's a far-right activist
they're they're both activists in this
respect and but one is first off defined
as being a
educational theorist so here here's the
point i brought up the other day
wikipedia right here this is whose name
is next to this statement
wikipedia in a comment section for which
section
230 is designed the username appears on
twitter
your picture and your username appears
on facebook your profile picture your
name appears
on wikipedia it says wikipedia the free
encyclopedia
james o'keefe from wikipedia the free
encyclopedia let me stop right there
the article says from wikipedia
i rest my case your honor i mean i think
you know
as i was saying before i think 230 has
been interpreted broadly enough by the
courts that it would probably
be a defense to any lawsuit based on
this stuff if so you're saying if i
write an r if i if i publish an article
if okay let's slow down
on timcast.com i take the comments from
people under a video
i then take the text right put it all as
an article
and then put timcast.com this article is
from timcast.com
and it says all of these insane things
they can't sue me
uh i mean it depends i mean they could
sue me but i could argue section 230
this is user generated content yeah i
mean i think you probably i mean
the way that it's been interpreted i
think you'd probably be safe i mean it's
been it's a very very broad grain of
immunity
i don't think we need it i i'm sorry
like i know it would very much disrupt
wikipedia's current model where
you know and i'm like good it's it's a
defamation engine that's what it is okay
i have a question
for anybody so 230 means that social
media
companies are not liable for what people
say on their site correct
so if you take that away wouldn't that
lead to more
censorship because if they're liable for
what people say
then take more of it off theoretically
it could mean that twitter can't exist
unless twitter vets the people who are
posting
and it might revert back to everyone
having their own website which
might be something better i mean the
thing that ian and i have been talking
about for the past i guess what three or
four weeks
is people having their own websites with
net open source networking technology
built in
so that if you have you know humane
events.com you can install this plugin
which creates a networking function
where you can choose what to exclude
from
you know people who are redirected but
it basically creates this recommendation
system
so that i'll say i definitely want to
have human events recommended in the
networking tab of timcast.com
and it creates a social media function
on my website
i mean i'd be okay with just a narrowed
230 that essentially allows twitter and
facebook to continue their current
business model
assuming they don't they knock off the
censorship and then also but also like
really puts the screws to wikipedia
right
you know because i think i think there's
something particularly damaging about
wikipedia
posturing is an encyclopedia that is
authoritative and yet it is just an
engine of defamation
it's an opinion an opinion aggregator
but but my main point is the other day i
was saying
that if you know i mentioned like your
username appears next to what you say
we say that's definitively definitively
from you what wikipedia does is it takes
the opinions
opinions literally opinions framing and
opinions of random people
but then it publishes them to a
front-facing page that says wikipedia on
top
in my opi and some of these articles
notably the james o'keefe article
is protected that means wikipedia has
decided the general public is not
allowed to edit this
only their select group of individuals
so what's defining this as user
generated
that they're not paying these people
that's it
yeah i mean well what do you think who's
who's got plenty of time
like i mean so so i can have users
three of them come over to the studio
and
i'll say anyone is allowed to to write
on this website so long as you're
a pre-approved user who's not getting
paid and they can write whatever they
want i can't be sued over it
that's that's an amazing standard the
the main issue though
is sure maybe someone argues yeah but
everything on the page is a user in the
back end it says
from wikipedia it doesn't say from user
john smith123
it doesn't say from ian crossland it
literally says james o'keefe
from wikipedia for encyclopedia they are
asserting they
are the the people speaking these
statements yeah
james i mean well we need we need to
we need to rewrite 230 so that it
doesn't cover this like i think
how does it how could it cover you
saying i wrote this
it shouldn't i mean but if you're saying
it does i i'm pretty sure that
under current case law it does so so
what if
what if i said oh won't someone
rid me of oh won't someone write me this
article claiming that ian did a backflip
it's just user-generated content i mean
you know maybe that's a little bit
closer to the edge because you could be
considered to be actively soliciting a
defamate defamatory content
i don't know i hope no one writes that
ian did a backflip
still same thing so what if i say we
allow everyone to submit
through the website's forms like
wikipedia whatever they want and then we
arbitrarily just publish some of them
i don't know good question i i wish i i
need to be deeper on
on the current 230 230 does not draw
distinctions
no it does if you're no platform you
have specific protections but if you're
a publisher
no so those words don't appear anywhere
like 230 what the heck
well publicly it's that you're not the
speaker of the content that's right it
says right and wikipedia is acting as a
new speaker of the company
it says it's a i'm paraphrasing but
online digital platforms cannot be held
liable for
content provided by users of that
platform and then it's
it also has an extra another provision
saying it you you cannot hold a website
responsible for the speech of its users
if they're acting in good faith to
remove
lewd lascivious or otherwise
objectionable it's it's
a slight tweak on that it's that you
can't they're they're not liable for
that removal right good faith remember
this is they're also shielded from
liability for that um
so they're allowed to moderate they're
allowed to remove things they don't like
and they're allowed to
literally publish things but it's it's
it's not their opinion so it's fine
is it for any website anything it's just
anything every network
all of them i don't think that this
should protect your contributors or
users
it projects it protects new york times
from their comments section no no
why wouldn't it protect an article uh an
article is like that's that's actually
the new york times
speaking right what's the difference
between the new york times
publishing an article wikipedia saying
from wikipedia uh
it's an employee of the new york times
who's actually writing the content
this is great this means we i can start
a newspaper and just not pay people
people would love to write for me and
then i can never be i mean you can just
put the pages on the website and let
people write
you know and and not well well look the
goal is like with wikipedia they put
protection on these articles so only
their select people can make changes
yeah i mean i think that that's an
interesting argument i wonder if that's
been tried it's
it's like we're deep into 230 law now
and i'm i'm not a
i am i know a decent amount about 230
but i'm not deep enough about like the
ex you know the finer
points of when something is live you
protected me when it's not all right how
about we just start a fund
raise a couple million dollars and then
just launch a volley of lawsuits based
on wikipedia claiming the articles are
from wikipedia
i mean we just let's just write some new
state laws like texas has got a great
law that that's in the book
on the books right now basically says if
you wrongfully censor someone for their
political beliefs you're liable they can
walk in a court get an injunction that's
great and get an attorney sees
but how do you how do you deal with the
the defamation machine
the defamation machine i think smear
merchants i think i think you need you
just need to amend the law that
basically says if you affirm if you
amplify
or like redirect the comments basically
what i think i think a world where
wikipedia was just a web page where
people could post
and that's all that happened right i
would i would be able to say okay
you're protected from liability for what
people post since you're just opening it
up to the world
but the moment wikipedia is redirecting
information about wikipedia entries to
google okay now you're speaking
right you're adopting these views now um
and so i don't know how to you know
i think you could probably write a law
it would be tricky to do it
but you're not going to get it at the
federal level yeah i mean
not not anytime soon so i mean maybe but
and the state law can't conflict with
federal law too so you can't that
particular law can be done at the state
level right if you
like if if it conflicts with existing
federal law revolving around
uh section 230 you know federal the
supremacy clause right
the federal government can't legislate
everywhere but when it does state law
can't conflict with it
so i guess we need uh we can't wait
for these laws to get passed i mean look
taxes might be doing that but
i mean you can try suits but i don't
think the suits will work right i really
think this is one of those cases
sometimes the federal government writes
a law that
you know insulates people from liability
and the only way to be able to sue them
in the future
is to get that law repealed all right so
someone needs to call ron desantis
and be like can you guys do this please
they're doing that censorship
they're doing a good censorship bill i
think the texas one's a little better
texas one's a little more focused on
protecting just average citizens the
florida one was like
focused on political candidates if i
remember correctly and didn't provide
like a broad private right of action for
citizens who were censored
um texas has got it nailed down texas is
doing it exactly right
when can we expect that you know i think
it's working its way through the
i don't know i'm not exactly sure i
might have passed already i don't know
i mean i know that it was uh governor of
texas announced his support for it
and i think it was if i got to be honest
if texas
passes that law some soon i think we
might relocate there i think it's a
strong possibility we
would we would relocate there oh yeah i
mean that would be the state where you
actually have protections now again
there's
there's another interesting problem
which is does 230 preempt that too
because 230 says you have this liability
shield for good faith removal
and texas is saying no you don't
effectively like private citizens can
sue you if you censor their political
beliefs
now you know maybe there's no tension
there because good faith might not be
political censorship that's one avenue
but there's also justice thomas had that
opinion a few
like a week ago i don't remember exactly
what day it came out oh yeah but he made
an interesting argument that he says
actually if federal law
preempts a state law that is granting
people free speech rights
the federal law has a first amendment
problem so
all right 230 interesting so 230 as
applied to try and
overturn a state law that protects
people's right to speak online
that might that as applied that might be
fall apart on a first amendment
challenge so that's i mean that that
hasn't been tested
at all but like literally that whole
opinion was just clarence thomas being
like hey states here's how you can like
protect
people if you want to try and here's
some ways that this will survive legally
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you